[Music]
the Swabian alb a range of low mountains
between stuttgart and lake constance in
southern germany
[Music]
the best way to enjoy nature here is on
a hiking trail for instance the vasa
fight strike
[Music]
unspoiled countryside forests meadows
and mountains the region is so unique
that it's received two UNESCO site
designations
[Music]
it sure is beautiful here in 2009 a part
of the Swabian up was declared a
biosphere reserve man at nature living
in perfect harmony I would like to find
out what that really means
[Music]
my hike takes me up to the teller horn
the lookout point offers a fantastic
view of horn salon castle a must see in
the Swabian alb the 19th century castle
has served as a backdrop for Hollywood
films
it sits atop that syllabic like a gothic
fortress the who and sullen certainly
built themselves an impressive structure
thus pizanno hunt is a bore Casillas I'm
not soon Alice when special about this
castle is that it's a national cultural
monument because it's the ancestral
castle of the House of Hohenzollern
the family of hereditary oppression
hence German kings and emperors it
attracts visitors from around the world
inside the castle you can find out more
about the whole salon dynasty the most
famous members of the family Prussian
King Frederick the Great and the last
German emperor villain the second
Warren Solon Castle is an attraction you
definitely shouldn't miss on a visit to
the Swabian alb
my next stop is the Bears cave in zone
booth
it's one of 2,000 caves in the Swabian
alb some of them like this one are open
to visitors
yell se Albin what you see glittering up
there on the roof of our cave are water
droplets dripping from pencil-thin
stalactites they look like an Italian
noodle specialty so we called them
macaroni macaroni bears used to
hibernate in this chamber scientists
have found the bones of more than 40
animals as skeleton is undisplaced
a tour of the cave takes about half an
hour
the Swabian alb biosphere reserve is not
only about nature the area also has 29
towns one of them is losing in its home
to the biosphere center in it I learn
more about UNESCO's network of biosphere
reserves there are more than 650 of them
worldwide including the Swabian alb the
head of the center tells me what's so
special about the region how did his way
be an out or in this title of biosphere
we have a bouquet of fantastic themes
there are large numbers of castles and
palaces here lots of caves you can
explore it's wonderful when I hear
biosphere reserve the first thing I
think of is conservation and unspoiled
nature
how do towns and car traffic fit in with
that biosphere reserves are about
protecting nature but also about people
establishing harmony between humans in
nature the biosphere areas protect
cultivated landscapes the Juniper
Heath's woodlands and Orchard Meadows
protect them by using them we have to
keep using these landscapes in order to
preserve them for people nature and of
course for tourism
many tourists who come here are horse
lovers the Swabian alb is perfect for a
holiday on horseback there are lots of
riding stables and fabulous countryside
to ride through as a beginner I need a
riding lesson I booked one at lisheen
wolf in Museum
all right let's go I'm a little nervous
but I think I know it's gonna treat me
pretty well you can also let go of the
reins and let your arms hang at your
side so you can relax a little okay
walking is fine at a trot I'm not so
elegant
[Music]
and at a gallop I start to tilt
backwards
tell me I'm a natural that's what I need
to hear to be honest
riding is something I've never been that
interested in but this time I had a lot
of fun actually I could do another lap
or two but I have plenty of more things
on my own every there's lots more to see
in the Swabian alb
I'm getting pretty hungry so it's off to
cafe laga house here all the cooking and
baking is done with local ingredients
some of the hotel and restaurant owners
in the area
have joined together as biosphere hosts
one of them is Eva hot lately
[Music]
but coffee and cake are great can you
tell me what this is it's plum cake with
plums spelt flour and eggs from the
Swabian alb and then here we have a
grain coffee
it's a Swabian specialty also known as
mukha fook
so this is 100% Swabian alb right
zelicah delicious you're biased fear
hosts here on the Swabian alb
just what does that involve we have to
fulfill certain requirements for one
thing there's the sustainability aspect
that starts with hydropower and also
includes the use of regional products
we're a group of about 20 restaurant and
hotel owners and we're really deeply
committed to the Swabian alb biosphere
reserve you know the ultimate Eastern
POS fan could be the ministry is not
absolutely everything you can buy here
in the lager house is handmade from the
soaps with regional hurts to chocolates
with Swabian ingredients you can take a
workshop to learn how to make these
tasty sweets today it's chocolates with
a chocolate chip filling and one unusual
ingredient
with vinegar by thermic vinegar and that
goes with chocolate yes very well I can
hardly wait
helping to make the sweets is fun after
they pooled they're dipped in chocolate
[Music]
then comes the decoration finally I get
to taste yummy what's good I've had a
pretty full program in the Swabian alb
now I get to relax a bit in the thermal
baths of Petula they are fed by hot
mineral springs from 770 meters
underground
the swadian out is the perfect place for
rest and relaxation and at the same time
there's so much to discover besides I've
learned something about our relationship
with nature plus I think the people here
really care about their region which is
also why it's such a fantastic
destination